s'agissant des projets de loi organique
et ordinaire conformément aux
engagements du président de la
république
les projets de loi organique et
ordinaire prévoient quant à eux une
réduction de 30% du nombre de députés de
sénateurs dans des conditions qui
garantissent la représentation de tous
les départements et territoires
l'introduction d'une dose de
représentation proportionnelle aux
élections législatives pour 15% des
sièges de députés à pourvoir
enfin l'interdiction du cumul des
mandats dans le temps
au delà de trois mandats identique
complet et consécutif pour les
parlementaires les présidents
d'exécutifs locaux à l'exception des
maires des communes de moins de 9000
habitants
l'objectif du gouvernement est de
permettre à l'assemblée nationale de
procéder à une première lecture de ces
textes avant la pause estivale puis de
parachever cette réforme en 2019
je veux redire que ces textes
contribueront à rénover profondément la
vie politique et parlementaire dans un
triple souci de responsabilité de
représentativité et d'efficacité je vous
remercie